hello everyone there are two major
tournaments taking place in the world at
this time the Tata Steel as you all know
since I've been covering it for the past
couple of days and there is also the
trade wise giver of Thor chess festival
which started on the 23rd of January and
will last till the 1st of February and
it also has some extremely strong
players there such as Levon Aronian the
Hikaru Nakamura here Penta La Hoya
Krishna
Maxine Varsha holograph Locke when glean
and of course vastly von Schuch
so definitely another strong tournament
and like I said it's it's not that cool
that the tournaments are overlapping but
again it's very nice that there are so
many chess events in the world that they
will eventually overlap so a lot of
content for chess and I just show you
one game by Nakamura and Russian
Grandmaster Valentina Goo Nina from
round 2 of the deep water chess festival
as I don't think I've ever shown a game
that lasts for a hundred and thirty-five
moves although only the first 32 moves
are really important so let's see this
game Nakamura has the white pieces and
he opens with E 4 we have c6 d4 and d5
the Caracara defense we have E 5 the
advance variation and Bishop to f5 kind
of inviting Nakamura to go for g4 as you
all know this is the bayonet attack but
instead of g4 Nakamura goes for h4 and
this is something called the tile
variation of the day advanced caro-kann
we have h5 h6 is also possible here
Bishop to d3 Bishop captures Queen
captures and East 6 now gooo Nina has
exchanged her light-square bishop she
placed all of her pawns on light squares
and now this bishop can freely walls
through the dark squares
Bishop to g5 attacking the Queen Queen
to a5 check and Knight the d2 now other
moves were possible but this night will
come come in very handy at the moment
Nakamura decides to push c4 to support
the C 4 square nice to e7
we have 90 to f3 Knight to f5 now and
Nakamura castles and here we have Queen
to a6 go Nina offers a trade of Queens
Nakamura
the client is now this c4 move comes in
very handy as the nighttime v2 is
supporting the c-4 square Bishop to b4
and here we have B three nights the b7
Rock F 2 c1 and the Bernina castles we
have a 3 and here you can either capture
the night on D - maybe retreat with the
bishop Guney now retreated with the
bishop if you capture with the bishop
capture send me to after Queen captures
you do have this Queen to b6 move
threatening the b3 pawn also may be
giving more pressure to the d4 pawn but
it's it's actually perfectly fight for
fine for four white White's and simply
push a four and now if you capture the
b3 point simply rook a to be one and
white will either grab the b7 pawn or
keep harassing the black Queen so after
a3 retreating the Bishop to e7
we have Bishop captures Knight captures
and now Knight to f1 Rema nuvaring the
night the g3 where it will attack the h5
pawn rook a to the 8th and now Knight
the g3 and D captures on c4 we have a
bit captures on c4 and now c5 and what's
what's the idea here is is it okay to
grab the h5 pawn it's it's perfectly
fine there's no reason to push g6 this
would only weaken the King side and
black will have black we'll have enough
counter play in the center and on the
Queen side an interesting variation here
however would have been the play Knight
to g5 this offers this threatens the
immediate check way a checkmate with
Queen to h7 this does force g6 and now
you capture the h5 phone now black can't
capture on h5 because going to h7 will
still be checkmate and after Knight to
f5 you play d4 Knight captures on d4 and
now after f4 it's an extremely sharp
position both sides have something to go
for it's it's very stranger i this
definitely looks like a position a
camera would go for but instead after
this e5 move he didn't go for this idea
he played the Queen to e3 we have C
captures on d4 Knight captures on d4
now Knight to g6 Knight to f3 was played
you don't want to capture the pawn now
as the or pawn on e5 is hanging so
Knight to f3 defending it and Queen to
a5 now there's a triple attack on d5
pawn so nakamora defensive rook to e1
and we have looked the c8 attacking the
c4 pawn and we have rook a to d1
that's there's no point in defending the
c4 pawn after go Nina captures that
Nakamura will capture on h5 so nice to
be 6 first as the rook was attacking the
knight on d7 now we have Queen to g5 and
now rook captures on c4 Queen captures
on c5 and on h5 and now Queen to a4
there's a triple attack now on the h4
pawn and here Nakamura played Knight to
e2 and what's the idea behind this
Knight to e2 why can't Guney not capture
this pawn on h4 well if you capture it
this would actually lose the game
immediately because of Knight to g5
threatening checkmate on h7 and after
you play Queen to c2 to defend this now
you have Knight to d4 ad there's the
idea of 92 now you attack the Queen the
only square Queen can go to is G's is g6
and also this knight on d4 is now
preventing this rook from c4 to defend
the knight on h4 so only movie screen to
g6 and I simply grab the night and
you're up a piece so a very devious plan
by Nakamura this Knight to e2 move
Knight to d5 was played and g3 now
taking away that's very important f4
square from both of black knights rook
to e8 and here we have a knight e to d4
probably possible was Knight to g5 with
some ideas of Queen to h7 but after up
to g4 it's it's very hard to find a move
here for for white haha how do you
continue this attack probably you have
to play something like rook to d3 maybe
bring it to f3 if this will be possible
it's hard to say but Nakamura doesn't go
for this after rook to e8 he plays
Knight into d4 we have Knight to f/8 and
Knight to g5 rook to e7 defending the f7
pawn as it was attacked and now comes
Knight to f5 and now you have to capture
tonight if you move the rook let's say
rook to d7 now this night is coming to
d6 now there's a triple attack on the f7
pawn you have to defend this probably
rook rook C to c7 and after rook to c1
attacking the defender it's a it's a
very pleasant position for white hard to
save it will be winning but probably
only white can win this position so
after Knight to f5 we have AP actors on
f5 and now rook captures on d5 rook to
d4 offering a trade of rooks and here
there are a lot of possibilities here
you can defend the road maybe Queen to
f3 you can also capture on d4
but as Nakamura decided to play the
towel variation of the advanced
caro-kann here he decides to play a very
nice tamil he plays d6 and now black has
plenty of options the first idea is can
you capture the rook
well if you capture the rook then you
get he captures on f7 with check rook
captures and after Queen captures came
to h8 only square and Queen captures on
f8 this will be checkmate so ok you
can't capture the rook but what else can
you play you can maybe capture the pawn
if F captors on e6 you get route
captures on f5 and after you capture
rook captures on e7 Queen to d1 forcing
a trade of Queens this comes with Czech
Queen captures rook captures and after
King to g2 it's hard to say material is
equal by the white is the white is much
better you're threatening to grab all
the Queen side points this night on g5
can never be pushed away locking out the
King from entering the game the f7 and
h7 Square are well covered if after you
try to exchange works maybe rook to d7
you get to look to e8 and black is just
paralyzed here so this would lead to a
much better position for white although
the material would still be equal so
another idea after a 6 maybe you can go
g6 a nice in-between move attacking the
Queen here you can
captured rook rook captures attacking
blacks queen and after Queen captures
now we play a captures on f7 this comes
with check rook captures and now Queen
to e2 the rook on f7 is still attacked
rook moves and now Queen to e8 and again
it's hard to find any any good moves or
or even a plan here for black black ink
is wide open
and like I said the material is still
equal but this is much better for white
so out of all of these options go Nina
decided to go f6 and this leaves
Nakamura with only one option and that's
to give up the Queen
he plays Queen to f7 check you don't
have any options here if you play King
h8 Queen Beatrice and I fade this will
be checkmate
so rook captures we have eg afters on f7
would check came to h8 and now comes
Rock to e8 the threat of course is if
the rook is captured rook captures night
on f8 so what do you play here rub the
d1 check first King to g2 and now comes
F captures on g5 and what's Nakamura's
best move here here of course you think
it's pretty obvious rook captures Knight
would check you pick up the rook okay
let's just show this rook captures with
check King h7 now you pick up the rough
Queen captures and now this very nice
rope to h8 check and white is winning
let's say King captures you bring up a
Queen King h7 only move Queen captures
on f5 next to grab the g5 pawn and with
two with being upon up in a Queensland
game like this this will be winning the
problem is after this rook capture some
on d1 the Queen will not capture the
rook there is actually Queen to c6 check
and after King g1 now there is came to
g6 not allowing rook 2hh to be
sacrificed with chick and after
something like rook after da threatening
to bring out a new queen king will
capture it and after H captors and g5
you will reach a position similar to the
one that was reached in the game so
after this F captors and g5 Nakamura
didn't capture the night the night is
still pinned no point in Russia
it he played rocky after sandy won we
have kinked King to h7 and now rook
captures on f8 and Queen to c6 check
King g1 and King to g 6h captures on g5
+ f4 now GK actors on f4 we have Queen 3
6 r up to d3 and now Queen to g4 check
Rob to g3 blocking and Queen captures so
here White has four pawns Black has
three points White has two rooks for a
queen it's hard to say it's definitely a
better position for white as the King is
wide open and two rooks will be able to
harass the King but this is only moved
43 so there's still a lot of work to be
done rope to d8 of course the threat now
is f8 bringing out the Queen King
captures and now rook to d7 check King
g6 rook captures on b7 Quincy 1 check
King King h2 we have Queen to f4 now
threatening to capture an f2 also
pinning the rook rook to be to defending
the pawn Queen h4 King g1 and queen to
d4 so so far gue Nina is doing a pretty
good job keeping those rooks at bay we
have rook be one Queen d2 rugby 3a Queen
e1 check King G to Queenie for check
there are four it's very usual in
positions like this you have to suffer
through a lot of checks before you can
make any progress
Queen to e2 again threatening the f2
pawn rugby to f3 Queen to d2 now raka
fate Queen to d6 we have rocked the c8 a
queen bee for Roxy 6 came to f5 rook f3
check King characters and now kingi to
Queen to b4 pinning the rook and
attacking get rook rook to c7
King to h6 defending the g7 pawn now
rook goes back to c3 King to h7 and rook
to e3 Queen goes back King gage - we
have Queen check rock blocks King to g8
rook to see three Queen to f4
King to g1 Queen to e5 rook to c4
Queeny one check kingi to Queen to e5
Roxy to g4 threatening now the g7 pawn
queen to d5 this comes up with a check
kingi one and now King to f8 now you
have to give up the pawn rook captures
we have Queen to d1 check King H to
Queen to d2 again going after that f2
pawn now rub the g8 check King f7 rook
three to g7 checking f6 rough to g6
checking f7 repeating checks a couple of
times and I wrote back to g2 defending
the bond Queen to f4
we have ripped the g3 blocking and now
Queen h6 check rook h3 Queen to f4 check
again can get one pinning the rook we
have rook to e3 Queen to d5 king h2
Queen to h5 again rook to h3 Queen e2
with rook to h4 Queen to f3 and a for
Nakamura has to push up on or otherwise
there will be the 50 move rule taken
over with a five rope to d4 Queen to a5
King to g3 Queen to c2 rook to f4 check
King to d6
e 6f3 and here we have another pawn move
so Nakamura is pushing that pawn forward
this is move 89 so it was about time
queen g6 check roadblocks we have Queen
B one rookie to King to f5 King g-tube
Queen to d3 rubgy 421 rugby - Quinta c1
rugby 5 King to f6 rugby for King e6
rugby to d5
we have Queen to c2 and now came to g3
and now those doubled rooks on the fifth
rank will be very useful in blocking the
checks delivered by the black Queen
Queen to a for grabbing that pawn we
have rookie 5 check King f6 Brooke f5
check King g6
rook F c5 came back to f7 rook captures
on e5 so no more points for black Queen
to d7
a rock to f5 check we have king to g6
rook
- d5 Queen e6 rookie 5 Queen d6 rogue d5
now 27 and now F for now the pawn
continues its journey
Quincy one we have rook to e2 Queen g1
check roadblocks Queen B one King to g4
King f6 and rook checks on d6
I came to a5 room G - D - 20g one King
to f5 Queen to be one check roadblocks
and now you'll see that those rocks will
be again very useful in blocking checks
from the black Queen Queen c2 Rock the
d7 check I'm making room for the King
King goes further now Queen B to check
but now it's very easy to block those
checks and make make make a path
available for that F pawn queen a one
Rock - dat check King h7 now f5 comes
Queen c3 King to f7 again making room
for the pond Queen to h3 now rook for 2d
522 g4 rock 8 d7 so if any checks are
delivered the White King moves it will
be checked at the black king queen h5
check King a 7 Queen to h4 check King
goes back Queen h5 check King f6 now now
black is in check King to h6 we have
Brooke five 2d six Queen to e1 now kind
of creating a wall against Nakamura skin
here as you can see came to f7 King g5
and now f6 and now that pawn is already
already it held too far up the board
Queen h5 check pink - pink the e7 and
Queen to e2 check King goes to a fate we
have king - g6 and now rock to g7 check
King goes to G - f v f7 now we have
Queen - a - king - king goes the g8 King
e5 rook to a6
the idea is to deflect the Queen so this
pawn will not be pinned of Queen
captures than pong can freely promote we
have Queen to see for keeping an eye on
that
F pawn to stay pinned and now comes
rubgy to g6 and this is move 135 and it
was in this position that Valentina
Guney not Russian Grandmaster resigned
the game
the threat of course is rook to e6 check
checking the King blocking the Queen's
pin to the f7 pawn and it's all over and
there's nothing you can do here if you
try and maintain this let's say Queen b3
doesn't really matter
rook checks you can either capture or
move it doesn't matter white brings up a
queen in every variation this is game
over so after rook G 2 G 6 a Valentina
gonna resign the game and this long long
game and a very nice victory for Hikaru
Nakamura I believe Nakamura won the last
three Geralt our chess festivals and
last year I think they awarded him
something extra for the prize hehe won't
first prize in in playoffs against Anton
the the Spanish Grandmaster but they
didn't just give him the prize I think
they gave him some special watch or
something and I think they said that if
he comes back next year and the wins
again that they'll give him something
even more extra little chess tournament
finishes I will try and cover some more
games from from get bored or just
festival so yeah that's the game it's a
pretty long game I do hope you enjoyed
it like I said first 32 moves are
important later it's pretty much just a
technique how do you how do you win
against the Queen which two rocks but
Nakamura managed to do it I think he
said that they played the game past
11:00 p.m. so you know we have to play
that game and then wake up tomorrow and
then play another game so very very
tiresome so yeah I would like to thank
Joseph Tyler for a contribution to my
channel thank a lot to really appreciate
it as usual you can check till my
previous videos here thank all for
watching I am interested how many of you
were actually able to watch this video
until the end
so do share in the comments if you were
able to think of for watching and I will
see you soon